Okay.
So what's coming for the next exam?
Well,
we've been looking at Adams,
uh,
and at the idea of orbitals for many electron atoms,
which we showed last time is wrong.
So today we want to recover from the orbital approximation.
Okay?
Then we're going to look at molecules.
And first we're going to look at them in a very unconventional way from the
point of view of plump molecules as plum puddings,
what's called the United Adam limit to apply what we know from atoms to
molecules.
But then we're gonna look at a very,
very different way of looking at it to try to understand bonds in terms of what
are called linear combinations.
That means weighted sums of molecular orbitals of atomic orbitals to make
molecular orbitals.
But we're gonna try understanding bonds and then these terms that don't mean
much to you now,
but will mean a lot later on.
Energy match and overlap.
And then,
uh,
we're going to get to reality.
All this stuff is theory,
but we're going to look at something real at x h three molecules with different
items for x at their structure and that at their dynamics.
And how that ties in with our understanding of bonding.
And then we'll go on to reactivity,
which is of course the main,
uh,
goal.
Uh,
we talk about homos and Lumos and you'll see what those are and how to recognize
functional groups in their reactivity.
And that's the real prize is to be able to,
you've been memorizing functional groups for this previous exam.
But what I want you to be able to do is look at a molecule and recognize when it
has a functional group,
even if you've never seen it before and how it might react,
what it would react with.
And then we're going to see how organic chemistry really developed the real
thing,
how it developed from the time of Lavoie Ca.
Uh,
okay.
So that's what we're going to do.
And here's where we were last time.
We were wondering,
when it comes to a two electron wave function,
might it be possible to write it as a product of one electron wave functions?
Because we know how to write one electron wave functions.
We've got that table.
We can write the real thing,
at least for an Adam.
Uh,
so if it were possible to write the,
the a six variable two electron wave function as a product of one electron wave
functions,
that would be a fantastic simplification and all we'd have to do is square and
we'd get the joint probability.
Not really that you care very much about the joint probability.
I suspect you haven't stayed up late nights worrying about joint probability.
But anyhow,
if you want to handle things with more than one electron,
you have to have it to electron wave function.
And if we could do it from one electron wave functions,
then we're really in a good position.
But we ended the last quarter of the first quarter of the semester on a downer.
The idea that there's no way electrons can be independent,
they repel one another.
So orbitals are fundamentally wrong.
Okay,
so forget that and here's our paradise.
It's gone.
Okay.
But are there tricks that would allow us to salvage or bottles to use them even
though we know they're wrong?
Okay,
well the first,
the simple minded trick is z effective.
We talked about how you could scale the one electron wave functions that at
atomic orbitals for nuclear charge,
if you take,
if you increase the nuclear charge,
they contract and we saw what is different properties are proportional to.
So if you have other electrons in the atom,
it could be that they could be sort of approximated as if they were just
reducing the nuclear charge,
right?
There's a certain repulsion as well as an attraction taking place if there are
other electrons there,
but maybe we can just reduce the attraction,
right?
And,
and uh,
things will be sort of at least correct it in the right direction,
right?
So pretend that the other electrons or some fraction of them are concentrated at
the nucleus.
So from the point of view of an electron,
you're thinking about,
they just reduce the nuclear charge and that's a problem.
We know how to handle what happens if you change the nuclear charge.
Okay.
So might there be an effective nuclear charge that we could use?
So we pretend the other electrons just reduce the nuclear charge for the
electron.
We're interested in the orbital,
the one electron wave function that we want to find.
So we're going to just try to find a one electron wave function in a many
electron problem,
okay?
And this is what we know that one s looks like that and row scales with z.
So if I just reduce z a little bit,
maybe I get something at least is corrected in the right direction.
Okay?
Now these guys,
Clemente and Ramondetta who worked at IBM in the early days when IBM was the
only place that had,
uh,
computers that were as powerful as your laptop or almost as powerful as your
laptop,
they did things like this where they did good quality calculations better than
than,
than this.
And then tried to match the wave functions they got by adjusting Z.
So they looked like the wave functions that you get with better approximations,
right?
So they've got a best fit to better calculation.
So they,
they found that helium,
which has two electrons,
so it has a nuclear charge of Tuesday equals two.
You get electrons distributed more or less,
right?
If you pretend that the nuclear charge is 1.69 instead of two.
Okay.
So each electron sort of what's called screens,
the nucleus that the electron from the nucleus.
Right.
Okay.
Uh,
now in the case of which has z equals six,
you can also use the effective,
but it's different depending,
depending on which electron you're talking about.
Why would that be?
So why would it be that you'd use a different screening constant or a different
effective z if you're talking about the one s orbital than if you're talking
about the two s orbital say,
why would,
why would it be different?
How much you want to reduce the nuclear charge?
Sherwin.
Yeah,
the electrons that are outside you don't care about.
It's the electrons that are between you and the nucleus that are screening you
from the nucleus.
Right?
So a one s is already really close to the nucleus.
There's very little other electron density that's inside it,
right?
That's why and helium,
it wasn't screened very much,
but in the case of of carbon,
that one s electrons,
which are way down near the near the nucleus,
have an effective charge that's almost six 5.67 but the two s have 3.22 right.
The one s electrons are all down inside and making the,
the nuclear charge appear small.
Right.
And to a certain extent the other,
the two P electrons are also inside to a certain extent,
but not as much inside as the one s is.
So 3.22 and the z effective for two P is different than for two s it's 3.14 what
do you notice about those two numbers?
You might think they'd be more or less the same and they are more or less the
same,
but two s is slightly less screened.
It sees more of the nucleus than the two P does.
Okay.
So it looks like two s gets more down inside than two p does.
Does that surprise you
Russell?
Yeah.
The dumbbell doesn't have anything at the nucleus.
Right.
It's got a node at the nucleus.
Whereas two s has that first little core down in the stuff that's inside.
It's first spherical node is down quite close to the nucleus.
Now we could look at that.
There's what two s looks like and here's the probability distribution that we
talked about.
R squared times the functions,
the radio function squared.
So this stuff that's in here is inside.
If we compare it with the two p orbital,
you'll see that this part is way down inside.
It's not being screened by the two plx trons.
Right.
In fact,
we could also look at the one s this is how the one s is distributed,
right?
So the one s will,
we'll screen this,
sorry.
And of course it's screens.
This part of the,
of the two s and it screens this are the two p.
But it's not really trivial to look at this and figure out which one would be
more screened.
The two s or the two p because this part is further in than this part,
but this part is way down inside.
So it's a balancing act as though as to exactly which one would be bigger.
And they're not very different.
But as it turned out,
according to Clemente and Ramon Day,
in their calculations,
that the z effective that you should use for two s is a little bit bigger than
the one you should use for two P.
Kevin,
why are there two peaks sent to us?
Because there's a radio node member two minus row.
The function is two minus row.
So at here's a zero to a zero when the distance is two two minus two is zero.
There's a node there,
okay?
And it's been squared.
Of course it's the wave function changes signed,
but here we square it.
Any other questions about this?
Okay,
now let's look at sodium.
So sodium has a nuclear charge of 11 and you won't be surprised to see that z
effective for the one s electrons of sodium is 10.63 almost 11.
They're very little screened.
A two s a 6.57 a two P is 6.8 but three s is only two and a half,
right?
Because it's further out still.
So they're more electrons inside.
Uh,
hiding the nucleus.
Everybody got the idea of what's going on here.
You notice one thing sort of funny here,
do you notice what
John Hot
turns around this time?
It's vice versa,
right?
So it's a balancing act and who knows?
And there's nothing fundamental about this.
This was just adjusted by Clemente and Ramon Day in order to get shapes that
look pretty much like better quality shapes.
Okay?
Uh,
so it's very subtle thing,
but this is very crude,
right?
Nobody argues that it's that it's the last word.
Uh,
so isn't there a better way to do it?
And there is a better way to do it,
to get back to orbitals even for many electron problems.
And that's called self consistent field or SCF.
And it's a recipe for calculating orbitals for calculating better orbitals than
you would get with an effective z.
So first you go through all the electrons in an atom or a molecule and you find
an approximate form of the orbitals.
For example,
you could use the effective to get something that's sort of approximate.
Okay?
So you have approximate wave functions,
square them,
you have approximate distributions for all the electrons.
Now with z effective,
what we were pretending was that a certain fraction of the other electrons are
on the nucleus and the rest of them we forget.
That's pretty crude.
Okay.
Now what we're going to do is pretend we know at least approximately how the
other are distributed in the cloud.
The other electrons,
we're interested in one electron and orbital right now.
How will knowing how the other electrons are distributed,
help us find the orbital.
We're interested in the one electron wave function.
What do you need in order to solve a quantum mechanical problem?
You need the mass of the electron.
That's easy.
What else do you need?
The potential law,
what its energy is,
it's potential energy at different positions,
but if you know where the nucleus is or nuclei,
right,
and you know the cloud of the other electrons and assume they're just static
clouds,
then you connect.
It's laborious.
You need a computer to do it,
but you can calculate the potential that the electron you're interested in would
have at different positions.
If there were this fixed cloud of other electrons and the nuclei.
So you have the potential law,
which means you can find your one electron orbital.
Okay,
did everybody see this?
The strategy here?
So we're going to do it one electron at the time.
So we,
we fix all the other electrons,
all but one from some crummy estimate like the z effective or something like
that.
Calculate the potential for,
for the one electron we're interested in.
And then we get use that potential to calculate an orbital for that one
electron.
That's better than if we had used as the effective,
right?
Because it's not just putting a certain fraction of the other electrons at the
nucleus,
it's treating them as a cloud.
Okay,
so now we have a much better guests for that one electron than we would have had
earlier with z effective or whatever type of gas.
What do you do next?
Any other work?
One of the time you,
you,
you now know how that one is distributed in the cloud,
much better,
right?
So,
and you take all the others but one fix them and their approximate clouds.
Now you calculate the potential for the second electron and do that.
Do that trick.
Okay,
so we've repeat steps two and three to improve the orbital for another electron.
Then what do we do?
Well,
what would you do at this point?
yeah,
it'll change shape.
That second electron will have a better shape now,
so you've got that.
You've got a good shape for the first electron.
Now you've got an improved shape for the second electron.
What do you do?
Or the first
are,
you know if there's a threat,
if there are three electrons,
you do the third one and then the fourth,
fifth,
sixth until you get through all the electrons and then start over.
So you improve all the orbitals one by one,
and then you cycle back to improve the first one again,
go through them all.
Then what do you do?
Start again.
Then what do you
do?
This is why it's good to have a computer,
right?
Then what are you doing?
When do you stop?
They'll stop.
At least you know,
it'll be like Arab and meets Goldie locks where it's out in the eight decimal
place.
That things are changing.
So then you know you've got in this closest as reasonable to go.
So you stop and what do you call it when you,
when you get to that sitch situation,
when you stop,
the system is self consistent,
right?
That's why it's a self consistent field.
Okay?
So you quit when the orbital steps shapes stop changing.
So now you have the right wave functions,
right?
The right orbitals.
So now we've got the real thing right or wrong.
What could be wrong?
We've got itself consistent.
Where is the,
where's the weakness in the assumption on which we'd been doing this?
Kevin,
I'm assuming what you're saying,
take the position.
You're assuming that
all those other electrons,
except the one you're working on are fixed in clouds,
but they're not fixed,
right?
The electrons can move around.
So depending on where your electron happens to be,
those other electrons may change their shape
at any given instant.
Okay?
It's still wrong because real electrons are not fixed in clouds.
They keep out of each other's way by correlating their motion right there.
Don't move independently so that this one is a cloud.
And this one moves around and nothing happens as this one moves.
When it gets near this place,
this one gets away.
Okay?
So they keep out of other ways by correlating their motion.
So the true energy must be lower,
more favorable than you calculate by self-consistent field because the orbitals
are able to get away from where you think they should be.
Is everybody clear on why that the limit goes in that direction?
Why the true energy is lower?
Because the,
the electrons are smarter than you are.
They know to get out of each other's way or at least the new pretended.
Okay?
So what do you do?
You hide the residual error so that people won't embarrass you by saying,
what the heck were you thinking?
Right?
You say that when you go to the heart tree foc limit,
which is a fancy name named after two people that stopped thought of doing this
self-consistent field thing or thought of a method for doing it,
right?
When you get to the heart tree foc limit,
that's self-consistent field,
but it's going to be an,
there's going to be an error because of correlation.
So you give it a fancy name.
So people will think,
ah,
that that's what in the heck is that?
They must really know a lot,
right?
So what do you call the error?
You call it error.
No Way.
Sophie,
do you know what you call it?
Correlation,
correlation.
Energy,
right?
There is no such thing as correlation energy.
That's not a fundamental energy.
It's not like cool ohms law or gravity or something like that,
right?
It's just the error you make when you do self consistent field that the true
energy is lower.
Now,
if you want to measure correlation energy,
what do you have to know?
You got to know the true energy so that you know how bad your estimate is,
right?
And where do you get the correct energy or the true electron density that you
have an error in.
You get it from experiment or you get it from some whopping calculation that's
not as simple as SCF.
Okay?
For example,
there's a thing called configuration interaction,
which we won't know anything about and don't need to write,
but it's a much more complicated calculation that takes into account the fact
that electrons keep out of each other's way.
Or there's another one called density functional theory,
which is also an approximate.
They're all approximations.
You can't solve the real equation,
but these are better approximations than just self-consistent field.
Okay.
But they're hard to think about because they involve so much manipulation that
it's hard to reason about them.
Self-Consistent field is easier to understand,
right?
So if we're really lucky though,
correlation energy might be negligible.
It might be so small,
we don't care about it.
In which case we're golden.
For practical purposes,
we use orbitals self-consistent field orbitals treat things as if they were
independent electrons.
Okay.
And then we're,
then we're in business.
Okay?
So we should think about the magnitude of energies and whether we care about
correlation energy,
this error that is in orbital theory.
What do I mean by saying orbital theory?
What's an orbital,
uh,
one electron wave function?
But we're trying to understand many electron problems.
Can we,
and the analyze many electronic problems as sums of one electrons as sums of
things that come from orbitals is the whole equal to the sum of the parts,
the parts being orbitals.
We know that orbitals have to be fundamentally wrong,
but if the error is,
if the correlation energy is really small,
we don't care.
So should we care about the error in orbital theory?
So here's a,
here are a,
is a scale of logarithmic scale of the energy changes that happen.
When did that occur?
When things happen,
and how big are these energy changes?
Let's start at the beginning.
So we take a bunch of neutrons and protons and bring them together to make a
nucleus and energy comes out right.
And the amount of energy that that is given off when a c 12 nucleus is formed is
two times 10 to the ninth kilocalories per mole.
How do I know?
Because I look at the mass,
the rest mass of the Proton and the neutron and I look at the mass of see 12 and
mass was lost when it came together,
right?
And the amount of mass last e equals MC squared is 0.1 atomic mass units,
which is two times 10 to the ninth kilocalories per mole.
So that's a lot of energy.
Okay.
Now,
so we've got c plus six,
now we're going to put two electrons on it,
the one s electrons of carbon,
right?
Bingo.
And that gives us two times 10 to the fourth kilocalories per mole given off
when that happens.
Okay.
Now that is our old familiar friend.
What do you notice about the ratio or these energies
tend to the fifth,
right?
So it's 10 to the fifth smaller like the ratio of my hair to the width of the
room,
right?
So much,
much smaller,
uh,
energy involved in putting electrons onto the end of the one s shell of carbon
than in putting the carbon nucleus together.
Okay?
Then we're going to put the vet four valence electrons onto carbon,
right?
The two s and two p.
And with that we get another three times 10 to the third.
So it's an order of magnitude less that one s electrons are bound much more
strongly than the two s and two p.
And you know that from this scaling,
right?
Z squared over,
over,
uh,
over end squared.
Okay?
Cause you could use z effective to guess how the one S is,
they're affecting the energies that the nuclear charge for the two s's.
So you could lower the nuclear charge from six to four because they're already
two electrons way down in there.
And then you have that end squared as well.
So you could scale the energy and find that it's an order of magnitude less.
Okay.
So then what are we going to do next?
Now that we have,
Adam's
going to put them together to make bonds.
Okay,
so we make four single bonds from carbon,
but there to other carbons.
So for this one,
carbon,
we should count only half of each energy,
right?
Because half of it will assign to the other carbon.
So half of four single bonds,
a single bond is order of magnitude 100 kilocalories per mole.
So that's about 200 kilocalories per mole.
So another order of magnitude down the energy and making bonds.
Okay.
And then we can have non bonded contacts.
Now there are different kinds of non bonded interactions between molecules and,
but typically they're in the rain to be worth talking about there in the range
of one to 20 kilocalories per mole.
So another order of magnitude down or more.
Uh,
okay.
And the weakest of all the weakest bond known or interaction known attractive
interaction is between two helium atoms.
It turns out that two helium atoms,
although they don't form a bond,
are attractive.
You know,
things that long distance or attractive and then they become repulsive.
So the minimum energy distance is 52 on strums,
right?
30 some times as long as a normal bond.
And the depth of that,
well,
how energy,
how favorable is that energy is two times 10 to the minus sixth kilocalories per
mole.
So that's nothing.
But all these things we're looking at down below here are all based on cool ohms
law.
The first one was not right.
The nuclear binding energy is not cool ohms law,
but all these others are cool ohms law.
But they're all 10 to the fifth,
up to 10 to the 15th times weaker than what goes on in the nucleus.
And that means if you made any error at all in the energy of the nucleus,
it would completely wipe out anything that had to do with cool ohms energy.
Right?
How's it so much bigger?
So an infinitesimal error in nuclear energy or change in nuclear energy during
our reaction would completely wipe out everything that we're talking about.
Right?
So this sounds like we would really worry about it except so a a 0.01% change in
nuclear energy would overwhelm everything.
Cool.
Ambig right?
But fortunately nuclear energy doesn't care about chemistry.
If you change from one arrangement of atoms to another,
the nuclear energy doesn't change at all.
Right?
So why is that good?
Okay.
You can just cancel it out.
Starting material and products of any reaction have exactly the same nuclear
energy.
So if you're not a physicist,
you can just forget nuclear energy even though it's so enormous.
Okay.
Is that clear?
So forget nuclear energy.
We don't have to worry about it.
All we have to worry about are these Coolum things now.
Uh,
so black that out.
Okay.
Now here's how big correlation energy is.
It depends on what problem you're dealing with,
how big the molecule is,
what kind of items there are in the molecule.
The error you make an SCF is different for different cases,
but for the kind of cases were interested in normal organic molecules.
It's of the order of a hundred kilocalories per mole.
Now that's an error.
Do you care about that error?
How big is that?
The error in in nuclear energy and air or would have been enormous and
completely wiped anything out.
Is this enormous?
Do we care about an error of 100 kilocalories per mole?
Dewey,
would you care about a era of another?
Uh,
Devin?
What?
Nobody you saying?
Would you care if you made an error of a hundred kilocalories?
Mole?
How big is that in the scale of things we're talking about?
Does this seem big compared to what?
That's the question.
What are we interested in?
Bonds?
How big is it compared to bonds?
It's as big as a bond.
A bond is a hundred kilocalories per mole.
That means that that we're designing.
That's disaster,
right?
Unless what?
The nuclear would've been a disaster too.
Why isn't it errors and nuclear energy or not a disaster?
Why?
Because they don't change the starting material on their product have the same.
So the same thing would be true here.
If correlation energy didn't change from one arrangement of atoms to another
arrangement of the same atoms,
then it would just cancel out and he wouldn't care.
Everybody got that idea?
Okay,
so the correlation energy is about equal to the magnitude of a bond.
But how big are changes in correlation energy when you change?
The arrangement of atoms will change,
tend to be about 10 to 15% as big as bond energy or 10 to 15% as big as,
as,
uh,
as correlation energy.
So correlation energy does change.
You make different errors for different arrangements of the same Adams,
but those errors are about 10 to 15% as big as a bond.
Now,
do you care about correlation?
You don't care as much.
So you'll get a proximate ideas if you don't care within.
If,
if you,
if you're satisfied with getting about 80% of the right answer,
right,
then you don't care,
okay?
So that implies that orbital theory is fine as long as what you're interested in
is answering qualitative rather than find quantitative questions.
Okay?
So if you want to get numbers really right,
and the magnitude of the number really makes a difference to you,
a few percent change,
then you have to do something better than use orbitals.
Okay?
But if you just want to understand why bonds work than orbitals are fine.
Because the correlation changes in correlation energy aren't that big.
So,
but for these properties,
for non bonded contacts,
especially for helium,
helium,
it's the correlation is the only game in town.
Often that's what holds helium atoms together.
Helium atoms are nuclei positively charged,
electrons negatively charged.
So nucleus or repels nucleus,
electrons repel electrons.
Nucleus attracts electrons.
Nucleus attracts electrons,
right?
They at first at 53 on strums or 52 Austrians,
far apart,
those essentially cancel,
right?
But the motion of the electron around this nucleus correlates with the motion of
the electron around this nucleus.
They tend to be in phase with one another.
So at any given time,
you have plus,
minus,
plus minus,
and they attract one another.
So that precisely what holds helium to helium is correlation.
So if what you're interested in is bonding,
then use orbitals fine.
But if you're interested in non bonded interactions,
then correlation can be a big problem.
Okay.
But we're talking about bonds now,
not correlation.
Okay?
So orbitals can't be true.
That's clear because electrons influence one another.
They repel one another.
If you have more,
if you have just one electron,
fine more electron orbitals can't be true.
But still we'll use them to understand bonding and structure and energy and
reactivity.
And we know that we won't get precise values will be off by by one to 10
kilocalories per mole,
but we'll get insight.
That's very useful.
Okay.
Now what gives atomic orbitals their shape.
Why does this uh,
particular orbital have a node?
For example?
We know coolamons law tends to attract the electrons to the nucleus.
Why does it have a node and spread out?
Yeah,
because of kinetic energy,
right?
This curvature of wave functions.
It's required to solve Schrodinger.
So its kinetic energy that gives,
gives them their shape.
Or if you double the nuclear charge,
the thing gets half as big.
That's cool.
Ohms law,
sucking it in,
right?
So the potential energy scales,
the radius through the formula for row.
We've seen that,
but the kinetic energy is what creates nodes.
So the two s has that spherical node or this orbital here has a conical to two
cones and a spherical node.
It's the four d orbital.
So kinetic energy is what creates the shapes.
The charge just scales things in and out.
Now if we use orbitals,
how should we calculate the total electron density?
Well,
we have two one electron wave functions.
We know that the density of electron one at this position,
by squaring its way function,
we know the density of electron to at that position by squaring it's wave
function.
How do we get the total electron density at that same position?
How would you get it?
You know how much of electron one is there?
It's probability density,
you know,
to how do you get the total Ilana?
Yeah.
If you know how much of electron one is there and you know how much of electron
to is there,
how much of a total,
like how much total electron density is there,
how would you get it?
Can't hear very well.
Yeah.
Adam together,
the whole is the sum of its parts.
Okay,
so the total density is the sum of those two squared wave functions.
The Stripe.
But notice it's a sum.
It's not a product.
This is not a question of joint probability.
It's not what's the probability that electron one and electron to are there at
the same time?
That's not the question.
The question is what's the total probability of finding any electron in there?
Okay,
so it's a sum.
It's not,
it's not a product.
Okay.
Now we had this question you looked at before,
how lumpy is the nitrogen atom?
This picture is taken from a recent organic text and they had fancy graphic
program or artist or something that drew something.
It looks very realistic.
Right?
But we can check it cause we know the formulas and if we want to get the total
electron density,
we add the electron density of the electron that's in the px and the one that's
in the p y and the one that's Pz orbital.
So we square them and we get this and we sum it up to get the total electron
density.
And it's some constant times x squared plus y squared plus z squared times e to
the minus row after we squared.
Right.
Uh,
and what,
how can you simplify that?
What's x squared plus y squared plus c squared?
It's r squared.
Okay.
So how does it depend on theta?
How does it depend on fee?
Elizabeth?
Does it depend?
What does it look like?
It's a sphere.
It's a ball.
It doesn't look like this thing.
So it's spherical.
So forget for all the elegance of that picture.
Forget it.
They're not showing you the truth.
Okay.
Or this problem we had before of looking at the cross section of the CN triple
bond where we sliced it and turned it and thought it might look like a
cloverleaf or maybe buy some kind of a diamond shape or something.
But in fact it's round.
Why?
Because two p x squared plus two p y squared,
it depends on x squared plus y squared,
which is r squared in two dimensions,
right?
So it's cylindrical doesn't,
doesn't depend on the angle around the bond axis.
Okay?
So this is what we've seen and we've seen a three dimensional reality.
Hydrogen like Adams,
we talked about hybridization.
Uh,
we saw the orbitals are fundamentally wrong,
but that we can recover from the orbital prop approximation and use it if we,
uh,
for example with self-consistent field,
as long as we're not interested in getting the very finest energy,
but our can be satisfied with approximation.
Now we're going to move on to something more interesting,
which is molecules.
We're going to look first at plum pudding,
molecular orbitals,
and then understanding bonds and overlap and energy match.
Now,
there are lots of different ways of looking at the electron distribution you
this story,
presumably about different blind men doing experiments on an elephant and
getting completely different ideas.
The same is true of the electrons in a molecule.
So here's the electron density in a hydrogen molecule.
It's calculated,
but there are ways to get that kind of information experimentally as well.
So you know how contours work this a lot more dense near the,
the,
uh,
origin near the,
near the nuclei.
So,
uh,
which contour do we want to look at in order to understand it?
Well,
we can choose our contour and we get different pictures,
different understanding,
depending on which contour we choose.
For example,
we could choose way down very high electron density,
right?
And then we see just the set of two Adams.
It just looks like two atoms,
right?
We don't see the fact that it's a molecule.
Where have we done this before,
Andrew?
Pardon me?
Not Different density.
Yeah,
total electronic.
We looked at total electron density.
It just looked like Adams.
We had to do the difference in order to see that it was not just Adams,
it was essentially just Adams.
So if you look at high density,
you see just a set of Adam's,
nope,
no excitement there.
So that's the molecule as a set of Adam's just to set of Adams.
Okay.
Or we could take a somewhat lower electron density contour and we'd see that the
atoms are a little bit distorted.
Or we could do a difference map is shy says in order to see that they're a
little bit distorted because of bonding distorts the shape of the atoms a little
bit.
But another,
but first,
and this is what we're going to look at shortly,
but first I want to get some insight by looking at the very lowest electron
dense.
So that would be molecules formed from a set of Adam's rather than as a set of
Adam's right there.
Little changes because of the bonds.
But how about if we look way out there now,
if you don't look a really close,
it looks spherical.
It looks just like an Adam or almost like an Adam.
And if you want to even further out,
it would get spherical for all you could tell.
Okay,
so that would be,
that's the molecule looking like an Adam with whatever number of electrons the
molecule has.
So that's the molecule as one Adam.
The only difference is that the nucleus,
which for an Adam would be in the middle,
has been split to give two nuclei,
which of course distorts the shape of the electrons a little bit if you move the
cut the nucleus into and split it out.
So we want to look at a few molecules from this point of view as single Adams
because we know about Adam's now,
but distorted by the fact that the nuclei has been split apart.
So this is nuclei embedded in a cloud of now what gave those electrons,
they're shape the shape of the cloud in which this thing is embedded.
What gave them their shape?
We just talked about this short time ago.
What gives orbitals they're shaped data
to be as far apart as possible.
That's potential energy,
right?
But that's not what gives,
that's not what creates nodes,
right?
That just causes things to spread out.
What gives them their characteristic shape of nodes?
Planar nodes,
spherical nodes,
and so on,
Elizabeth,
it's the kinetic energy and the same kinetic energy considerations will apply in
a molecule as in anatomy.
It's always curvature of the wave function divided by the wave function.
So there,
so the electrons are dispersed by electron repulsion and noted given nodes by
the kinetic energy.
And the kinetic energy also causes them to spread out as we've seen before.
Okay.
But you see them that although Thompson was wrong about the Adam,
it wasn't a plum pudding of Nuclei embedded in a cloud of positive charge.
But a molecule is a plum pudding.
It's nuclei embedded in a cloud of negative charge.
But that cloud of negative charge is given its form by kinetic energy,
largely also potential energy as you say.
So it's backwards from what Thompson thought.
But his idea,
it wasn't a silly one.
It just happened to be wrong for Adams.
So here's a piece of plum pudding in which you know is like fruit cake.
So how do the plums distort the pudding,
right?
We know that.
We know what what Adams would look like now,
right?
But if you split the nucleus into several nuclei and move them around as the
plums in the pudding,
they'll change the shape of the electrons.
How?
That's what we want to look at today.
Okay.
So first we're going to look at methane and ammonia and we want to understand
them visually.
Why do they have the,
why do the orbitals in these molecules have the shapes?
They do?
Okay,
so there are four pairs of Valence electrons.
There are also two core electrons,
one s electrons on carbon and on nitrogen.
So we want to compare the molecular orbitals to the atomic orbitals of Neon,
which has the same number of electrons for electron pairs within equals two in
the neon atoms.
So there's the same number of electrons is neon.
So they should add a big distance.
If you look at very low contours,
it should look like a neon Adam.
But what does it look like as you get closer?
Okay,
so here's a one s orbital of the Neon Adam,
right?
And here's the one s orbital of methane.
It's that net that shown the red net.
Everybody see it?
And here's the contour level that we're drawing is where the,
we know which level are we choosing.
We're choosing 0.01 electrons per cubic [inaudible] is the level we've chosen to
draw of the onion,
right?
And here it is for nitrogen.
The blue when there is is the lowest molecular orbital,
but they're just little spheres right there,
like the one s of of uh,
uh,
of,
of a neon.
Okay.
So the core orbitals are like the one s of the carbon or nitrogen atom there are
tightly held.
They aren't distorted very much because the nuclei have split apart,
right?
And they're boring.
So forget them.
We won't talk about them anymore.
We'll focus on the valence orbital swear.
The bonding action will occur.
Now they're eight valence electrons.
That means to them orbital.
So there'll be four molecular orbitals that have electron,
send them in methane and they,
they are arranged in energy this way.
There are,
there's a lowest energy and then there are three that have exactly the same
energy.
Do you remember what those are?
What we call those when several orbitals have the same energy degenerate.
Okay?
So there are three degenerate molecular orbitals for ch four that have exactly
the same energy.
In the case of ammonia,
it's a little different.
There's one lowest one and then there are,
uh,
there are three,
but one of them is higher than the other two.
They're only to degenerate ones there,
incidentally.
What does that remind you have to have one that's a little bit lower and then
three that are the same energy.
Have you ever seen that before?
Ah,
two s and two P,
right?
There's one,
two s and three two peas in an atom,
right here is a molecule and there's one that's lower and then three that are
equivalent.
Okay?
Now there's the lowest one and it's a two s orbital.
It's the analog,
it's the night the,
the neons two s orbital.
That's been distorted by taking four protons out of the nucleus and pulling them
out to be where the hydrogens are.
Okay?
So you can see how this has been distorted by distorting the electron cloud into
the direction where the protons had been pulled out.
You see that,
okay,
now you don't see that you have to remove the ball there.
That's the carbon or the nitrogen to see that little spherical node.
It's way down near the origin that made it a two s orbital,
right?
That's the spherical node and it doesn't look like a sphere because of the
algorithm the computer uses to draw this connecting dots with straight lines,
right?
But it is more or less spherical,
a little bit distorted by the fact that you've pulled these things out.
Okay?
Now what do these molecular,
these are molecular orbitals,
but that you see is a two p x orbital.
That's been a little bit distorted,
right?
Notice that,
that the difference between the ch four in the Nh three,
there was a proton that went up and ch four,
right?
Which pulled the,
which can come up,
pull them up.
But if you didn't have that,
it didn't go up as high,
right?
But then it's essentially,
this is the two px orbital of the molecule distorted from the Adam by pulling
protons out of the nucleus.
Okay?
Or that one.
What's that one?
It's two P y.
But you have to rotate it to see it.
If we rotate it 90 degrees here,
you can see that it's two p.
Why orbital and again the the ch four is distorted that the top because two
protons came out and stretched it out.
Same thing in nitrogen.
Now we go to the,
to the third of these two P orbitals,
which is different in nitrogen for the nitrogen case.
Higher an energy.
There they are.
Why is that orbital higher in energy than the others in nitrogen?
Why isn't it so good?
Because you have electrons up in that red region that don't have a proton there.
It's not being stabilized here that the electron density that went up is,
is around a proton.
They're the top lobe of the p orbital,
right?
Doesn't have a proton stabilizing it,
so it's,
it's,
it's higher in energy and turns out to be more reactive.
What do you call it?
That's the unshared pair.
The high energy reactive electrons are the ones that don't have a proton
stabilizing up there.
Now there are also vacant orbitals,
right?
Remember it?
You can have any number of orbitals.
We're looking at the ones that you can make from the two s and two p.
But we have to add that we have,
uh,
we have,
a number of,
of,
uh,
of atomic orbitals that we can use.
We're looking at the lowest set,
the ones that come just from one s orbitals of hydrogen and two s and two p
orbitals of carbon or nitrogen.
But there are eight such orbitals,
four two s and three two p's on the central atom for,
on the hydrogen for ch four.
So there'll be a number of other combinations you can make from mixing those,
uh,
which won't have electrons to go in.
And,
but let's look at them.
So here are the next four orbitals made from the valence level orbitals of the
Adams involved.
So what you see on ch four that this is the three s orbital.
It has a radial node,
right?
There's our,
pardon me,
yeah.
Radio or spherical node here that surrounds here.
So it's red sign inside blue sign outside.
The same thing is true on the,
of the Nh three,
but you have to rotate in order to see it.
Uh,
that's the lowest vacant,
the lowest unoccupied molecular orbital.
And if we,
uh,
if we rotate it here,
you can see the inner part and bear in mind that there are two spherical nodes.
There's one that's really tiny that's inside anything we can see here.
Okay?
Then there's this orbital,
which is the three d x squared minus y squared looked at from a funny angle
where it's not very clear what it is,
but if we rotate all of these by 90 degrees,
you can see that it's like that,
that uh,
that cross or whatever you call it,
of the three d x squared minus y squared.
But why doesn't it look just like that?
Why are they distorted?
Why does it have this funny u shape here instead of this lobe,
this lobe here and here?
The lobes moved up there.
Why
Angela?
Pardon me?
That's where the protons pulled them.
The potential energy,
but the fundamental shape before it got distorted by the potential energy of
where the protons are.
The fundamental shape was from the kinetic energy.
It was like the three d x squared minus y squared.
Or how about this one there you can see,
but it's clearer still if we rotate it that again,
it's that,
uh,
that,
x shape thing,
but the ones on top of been pulled out by the protons or this one,
that's the one that has a doughnut around the middle,
but the donut has been pulled down by,
by the three hydrogens,
uh,
that,
that aren't on the exit on the z axis or here.
There it is rotated.
Okay.
Now,
um,
I hoped to get let,
let's just start FAA and methanol and then we can get to a better,
more interesting things in it next time.
It has a lot more pairs of electrons,
ethane,
and Methadone.
So we can compare those ammos to the Aos of Argon,
which has the same number of electron pairs.
Uh,
actually I should quit now and let you get to your next appointment.